clic clic waouh tu fais ip à bien le
clic merci abonne toi t'as vu robin ça
va non je suis en galère pour mes
cadeaux de noël à dakwa comme budget
vraiment pas lourd
alors j'ai peut-être une idée pourquoi
l'année dernière au moment de noël je
vous avais donné une idée cadeau
originale extrêmement généreuse est
complètement gratuite
le don de moelle osseuse vous avez été
très nombreuses et très nombreux à vous
inscrire sur les listes
et ça c'est beau du coup bas cette année
faut retrouver une autre idée et ça
tombe bien parce que j'ai une nouvelle
idée cadeau pour vous du sperme
oui non mettez pas votre petit flacon
sous le sapin même joliment emballé ça
peut surprendre
je vais vous expliquer comment ça se
passe d'abord pourquoi donner son sperme
enfin à qui on le donne exactement et
puis surtout qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
avec
alors à la surprise de personnes ça va
servir à faire des bébés pour des gens
qui peuvent pas en faire par leurs
propres moyens pour être très clair
la loi prévoit que la procréation
médicalement assistée la fameuse pma
elle est réservée aux couples
hétérosexuels qui ne peuvent pas avoir
d'enfants à cause d'un problème de
fertilité diagnostiqué par un médecin
mais la loi de bioéthique qui gère ce
genre de questions elle est en train
d'être réétudié et elle pourrait
permettre l'ouverture de la pma à toutes
les femmes y compris les célibataires et
les couples du même sexe
cette proposition de changement de la
loi elle a été votée par l'assemblée
nationale en première lecture elle doit
encore passer devant le sénat
et elle sera pas adopté avant courant
2020 donc pour l'instant la loi a pas
changé ceci dit dans tous les cas donné
son sperme s'est donné la possibilité
d'avoir un enfant à des gens qui peuvent
pas et ça c'est quand même un sacré beau
cadeau chaque année il ya trois mille
couples qui s'inscrivent pour bénéficier
d'un don et vous vous doutez bien que si
je vous en parle c'est qu'on manque de
matières premières accessoirement les
couples receveur ils peuvent demander
que leur futur bébé
il est une apparence physique le plus
proche possible de la leur et ça ça peut
encore rallonger les délais d'attentes
parce que les origines ethniques
elles sont pas toutes aussi bien
représentés parmi les donneurs donc plus
il y aura de donneurs plus il y aura de
diversité parmi les échantillons et la
diversité c'est toujours bon donc donné
ok mais bon est-ce que tout le monde
peut être donneur pas qui peut donner
déjà il faut être équipés du matériel
nécessaire à la fabrication de
spermatozoïdes donc il faut être un
homme pour simplifier un homme entre 18
et 45 ans pour être précis et un homme
en bonne santé mais ça on va revenir
dessus un petit peu plus tard oui vous
entendrez aussi parler de don de gamètes
une galette c'est pas un petit stickers
colorés qu'on colle sur un dessin moche
une gamme est c'est une cellule
reproductrice donc les gamètes femelles
c'est les ovocytes et les gamètes mâles
c'est les spermatozoïdes et c'est de ça
qu'on parle aujourd'hui
mais bon même avec la meilleure volonté
du monde c'est très difficile de ne
donner que ces spermatozoïdes vous
souvenez le sperme c'est un cocktail
je vous avais donné la recette donc on
donne son sperme c'est plus commode mais
avant de voir concrètement comment on
fait il faut savoir trois choses
importantes sur le don de sperme le don
de sperme c'est gratuit je comprends que
vous vous posez la question mais la
réponse est non on va pas vous payer
pour votre contribution
c'est un acte de solidarité par contre
si vous devez vous payez rien un bien
sûr et on vous rembourse vos frais de
transport par exemple
faites attention le don de sperme
sauvage ça existe oui alors c'est le don
qui est sauvage pas le sperme
ça existe mais non seulement c'est
illégal mais en plus ni le donneur mis
les receveurs ne sont protégés par
toutes les précautions qui sont mises en
place dans le cadre d'un don légal donc
fait passer le don de termes et
volontaire oui alors ça paraît évident
mais c'est quand même bien me le dire on
ne peut pas vous forcer je vous jure
j'ai pas de l'équipe sur moi
concrètement ça veut dire que vous allez
signer un formulaire de consentement
et si vous êtes en couple votre
partenaire aussi ça sera peut-être
changé avec la modification de la loi
mais pour vous ça restera indispensable
le nom de ferme ces anonymes
actuellement c'est la loi il n'y a aucun
moyen pour les enfants nés d'un don de
sperme d'avoir des renseignements sur le
donneur et réciproquement comme on l'a
vu la loi de bioéthique
elle est en train d'être réévalué donc
il ya des choses qui pourraient changer
aussi à ce niveau là mais pour l'instant
ça reste à venir bon avant d'aller plus
loin je sais que vous vous posez la
question et c'est bien normal
comment ça se passe concrètement quand
on donne son sperme nantais pas je sais
que vous vous demandez et qui a plein de
fantasmes autour de ça vous vous
imaginez peut-être que c'est une machine
qui fait le job
alors je vais pas mentir la machine elle
existe et les chinoises mais non on
n'utilise pas ça en france on n'utilise
aucune machine en fait ce n'est pas non
plus un truc médical ou chirurgical
ça se fait de manière artisanale selon
une technique ancestrale que tout le
monde connaît ok je vous vois là encore
vous vous imaginez des trucs bien non
c'est toujours nous vous vous
débrouiller tout seul enfin pas
forcément bon je vous explique d'abord
c'est pas comme pour une analyse
d'urines vous pouvez pas faire ça chez
vous est arrivé avec votre petit flacon
les spermatozoïdes cd petite bête
fragile donc pour éviter de les abîmer
il faut faire ça au centre mais
évidemment vous avez une salle
spécialement aménagée pour ça rien que
pour vous et vous avez tout le temps
qu'il faut il ya même des revues à votre
disposition qui sont susceptibles de
vous aider
mais comme tout le monde n'a pas
forcément les mêmes goûts vous pouvez
amener les vôtres pas de soucis vous
pouvez même amener votre smartphone ou
votre ipad etc
on se comprend et donc vous vous
débrouiller tout seul sauf si votre
conjointe ou votre conjoint veut donner
un coup de main ça c'est possible
bon maintenant que vous savez tout ça et
que vous êtes rassurés pour en arriver
là
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et bah ça se
passe en plusieurs étapes d'abord vous
prenez contact avec un centre de dons je
vous mets liens dans la description pour
que vous puissiez trouver le plus proche
de chez vous ensuite on vous donne
rendez vous au cours duquel on vous
explique comment ça va se passer et on
s'assure de votre consentement est
indispensable le consentement toujours
puis vous avez une consultation avec un
médecin qui
vérifiez votre état de santé et qui fait
un petit peu le tour de vos antécédents
médicaux avec on vous fait aussi
quelques examens pour déterminer votre
groupe sanguin et pour vérifier que vous
n'avez pas de virus ou d'anomalies
génétiques transmissibles
si vous avez envie ou besoin ou les deux
vous pouvez discuter avec un psychologue
pour faire le point sur vos motivations
à devenir donneur ce que ça représente
pour vous comment vous vivez et tout ce
que ça implique
arrivé à ce stade vous allez pouvoir
faire un premier don qui sera analysée
en fonction des résultats à l'équipe du
centre va déterminer le nombre de dons
que vous aurez à faire
en général ces quatre ou cinq ans
plusieurs fois et pour finir mais c'est
indispensable six mois après le dernier
dont on refait quelques examens pour
vérifier que vous n'avez pas de virus
comme le vih ou une hépatite c est le
genre de chose qui peut ne pas se voir
dans les premiers examens à cause des
délais d'incubation et une fois que tout
ça est fait votre sperme et conserver en
attendant d'être utilisés il est congelé
sous forme de paillettes et quand un mec
de paname a dit kevin il vous reste deux
trucs importants à savoir d'abord pour
ceux qui n'ont pas encore eu d'enfant
vous pouvez garder un peu de paillettes
de côté pour vous pour le cas où vous
auriez vous même besoin un jour d'une
pma on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
ensuite vos échantillons ils vont pas
servir indéfiniment c'est pas un open
bar
ils pourront servir que pour donner
naissance à 10 enfants maximum pour
éviter les risques de consanguinité
quand les enfants seront eux mêmes en
âge de faire des bébés ah oui et alors
pour clarifier un truc non vous n'aurez
pas de carte de donneur si elle veut pas
de vous en a montré une c'est qu'il a
achetée dans une carterie au rayon bof
et sert à rien à part vous questionnez
sur l'humour de vos amis virtuels
alors vous allez me dire et si je peux
pas donner de spermatozoïdes je fais
comment pour noël mois et bat tout le
monde peut pas donner mais tout le monde
peut aider je veux dire sans aller
jusqu'à a braqué une banque de sperme
pour faire un cadeau à un couple dans le
besoin on peut faire un ou deux trucs
qui aident en parler autour de soi ou
faire tourner cette vidéo ou faire
tourner les liens que je vous mets dans
la description ça c'est déjà bien tout
ce qui pourra décider des donneurs
potentiels à franchir le pas c'est super
précieux et puis on peut
donner c'est au beau site qui on en
possède alors peut-être l'objet d'une
autre vidéo mais en attendant je vous
mets tous les liens utiles dans la
description là juste en dessous voilà
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
[Applaudissements]